Hello everyone, I'm Dr. Emilia Javorsky from the
Future of Life Institute where at the institute I
lead up our efforts on lethal autonomous weapons.
And I am super thrilled to be here today to
speak with this amazing group of people who hail
from very different backgrounds and perspectives,
but something they all should have in common is a
great dedication and work on working to safeguard
our world from the from lethal autonomous weapons.
And so we're coming together today because we're
really at a pivotal moment in this issue for the
world to decide what our future will look like
with autonomous weapons which we define as
weapons that use AI to select and apply force
against targets like human beings without human
intervention. And over the next few weeks the UN
is slated to meet in Geneva at something called
the Convention on Certain Conventional Weapons
to debate this issue to debate what should
the world do about the threat of autonomous
weapons. And at the heart of that question is the
determination that this is the moment where the
global community is going to make the decision,
"Are we going to allow AI to decide who lives
and who dies?" And because of this urgency
and because of the magnitude of the issue
that we're dealing with at the Future of Life
Institute, we are releasing a short film that
is really a follow-up to a film we released back
in 2017 called Slaughterbots. When we released
that first film, that was really a film aimed
to raise awareness about the issue of lethal
autonomous weapons and sort of put it on the map.
Now, three short years later sort of since we've
released that film, we're living in a world in
which we're already seeing media reports across
the globe of small companies producing these types
of weapons and them being used on the battlefield.
And so we decided to create another short film to
both follow up in warning people of that risk but
also depicting what is the kind of thinking that's
happening right now that's driving us towards that
end point. And, more importantly, what is it
that we can do about it and what can the world
do about it given this really important moment
that we have with this UN meeting to perhaps
steer ourselves in another direction. So that was
why we put that film together. But the panel today
is to kind of from the realm of storytelling into
the realm of reality and hearing these different
perspectives on the state of lethal autonomous
weapons and also what are our policy options
for moving forward. And so with that I would
like to bring together onstage our great panel,
and I would like each person to sort of kick this
off by introducing themselves and telling us a
little bit about who you are, what organization
you're with, and your perspective on this issue.
So I will start off with Max. It's an
honor to be here. I'm Max Tegmark, yeah
I'm a Professor at MIT where I work on a
little bit of physics. But mostly AI research
for the past five years. And I'm also one of
the founders of the Future of Life Institute
because I love technology and I believe
that artificial intelligence in particular
has the potential to be the most awesome
technology ever helping life flourish
like never before. But it also has the potential
to be the worst thing ever to happen to humanity.
And I think this issue of lethal autonomous
weapons is really really the first fork in the
road where we have to make the right decision.
Because the key to a wonderful future where ai
helps us cure diseases and helps live
let's live healthy and wealthy and
inspiring lives or is to draw a clear red
line between all of these wonderful uses
and the small set of really really terrible
uses which would ruin everything. And if we
can't even agree that we don't want to use
ai to anonymously kill people and to decide
entirely on its own who lives and who dies now
who are we kidding that we're ever going to be
able to draw any kind of lines just be our ai
towards towards the good future that we all want.
Awesome. Thank you Max. Stuart. So i'm Stuart
Russell, I'm a Professor of computer science
at the University of California Berkeley. I've
been doing artificial intelligence there for
more than 35 years. And I'm also director of
the Center for Human Compatible Artificial
Intelligence and like Max, I am very
concerned that AI be beneficial for
the human race in future. And I share his
optimism that it can be enormously beneficial.
I've been concerned about autonomous weapons since
around 2013. Initially as a member of human rights
watch which participates in the campaign to stop
killer robots. But also as an expert testifying
at the United Nations, I've come to believe
that pushing forward with autonomous weapons
would be disastrous for international security
and even domestic security. Wonderful. Richard.
Hi Emilia. Hi everybody. I'm Richard Moyes from
article 36 which is an NGO based in the UK. We
also coordinate the stop killer robots campaign
which is a partnership of non-governmental
organizations more than 180 organizations
i think now who are concerned with this
issue who are pushing for states to develop
an international legal treaty on this
issue. I suppose my background is really in the
world of weapons. I worked for like my clearance
organizations in the past and then i've been
working in the world of weapons policy and law so
really coming at it not from the ai side but
from the side of thinking as a society about
well frankly how we're allowed to kill each other
in in these international in these international
settings and recognizing I think Max used the
term drawing lines recognizing that when it
comes to how we we kill each other how we engage
in that you know very primitive practice in a way.
But there's a social recognition that we need to
draw some lines, we need to draw some boundaries
about the role of technology in that. And when
we start to look at autonomy and weapon system I
think we also see the need for the clear lines to
be drawn in this area to sort of set expectations
in society that frankly killing people is
always going to be problematic. But giving
machines the power to kill people is just is just
crossing a line that that's unacceptable to us. So
we're working as a partnership to
secure a legal outcome on this issue
Maya. So, my name is Maya Briem. I'm
a legal advisor at the International
Committee of the Red Cross or in short ICRC.
The ICRC's exclusively humanitarian mission
is to protect the lives and the dignity of
persons affected by armed conflict, war,
and other situations of violence. And the
ICRC acts to preserve people's lives and
livelihoods and provides assistance to them,
to people in need. And we also seek to prevent
suffering by promoting and strengthening
international humanitarian law the IHL.
That's the law applicable to war and broader
universal humanitarian principles. And so
part of the ICRC's work since its inception is to
support states in the development of international
humanitarian law including to prohibit or regulate
certain weapons based on a realistic assessment
of their adverse humanitarian impacts. So in the
past the ICRC's, the ICRC has played an important
role for example in the processes that led to
treaties prohibiting anti-personnel landmines
or the treaty prohibiting cluster munitions.
And in more recent years the ICRC has given
focused attention to emerging technologies of
warfare. So, new forms of waging war, new weapons
enabled by developments in science and technology,
including of course autonomous weapon systems.
Wonderful. Thank you all so much for being here
today. I can already tell in sort of our opening
statements, there's a lot of differences
in sort of our perspectives of concern. But
I already sense that everyone has some degree
of optimism that something can be done on this
which is is a good place to start. So I'm really
excited to sort of dig into the content here on
autonomous weapon systems you know. From from my
perspective, I'm a physician by training, and I
came to this issue in thinking about how we think
through the use of ai and life and death decisions
in a very different context - which is in the
context of saving lives. And in that thinking
our professional association the American Medical
Association developed a policy in which they don't
even recognize artificial intelligence. They say
when it comes to life and death decisions it's
called augmented intelligence because there's
an irreplaceable role of a human being and
human judgment when it comes to thinking through
decisions that affect a human being's health and
well-being. And so it always struck me that it was
totally absurd that on this parallel conversation
we're having about hey let's use AI to kill people
without humans in the loop right? This strikes for
me a really deep moral problem right? And that
there is a fundamental moral issue here with
allowing algorithms to make the decision over who
lives and who dies. And so the moral dimension is
certainly I think one. But I'd be interested to
know from each of your different perspectives
how do you think through what are the problems
with lethal autonomous weapon systems? Why
are they so bad? And why are we all here sort of
dedicating our time to do something about them?
So I'll kick that off with Stuart because I know
you've been thinking through different dimensions
of this for quite some time. Thanks Emilia. Yeah
I think the moral dimension is very important. And
I know that some very significant figures
including the Secretary General of the United
Nations believe that the moral aspect is in fact
decisive that these are morally unacceptable
weapons. Even if I share that view and I think I
do. I don't think it's going to be persuasive to
governments who don't trust the moral behavior
of other governments. Because even though
the moral governments might refrain from using
such weapons, they're not going to trust the
other governments to do the same. And so they're
not going to agree to a treaty on that basis.
When I think about autonomous weapons, to me
the main characteristic that they have that's
different from other weapons, we have some
pretty horrible weapons that are so-called
allowed already, the main difference is
that they don't require a human being
to be there supervising or pulling
the trigger or launching the missile.
And if you know anything about computer science
what we know is if a computer can do something
once, it can do it a million times or a billion
times. They're very very good at doing the same
thing over and over again in vast quantities. We
call this scalability in computer science and it's
a it's seen as an asset for computers because
it it lets them do lots of tedious calculations
without a human having to insert themselves
in every single one of those calculations.
But when it comes to killing, that means that
you can launch a million or 10 million weapons
simultaneously you know from a small control
center and wipe out entire human populations.
You can do it selectively so you could wipe out
you know all males of military age for example,
you could wipe out all persons visibly belonging
to a religious group or an ethnic group.
And do we want to be part of this kind of
weapon? It would seem to me that they would
replace nuclear weapons in almost all of the
roles that people have for nuclear weapons
because they're cheaper, they're easier to build,
they don't leave behind a radioactive crater,
they leave all the physical assets intact, and
we don't sell nuclear weapons in supermarkets
for a good reason. It's not a moral reason. It's
a practical reason. And if we allow these kinds
of weapons to go ahead it will be just as if we
were selling nuclear weapons in the supermarket.
So, democratized weapons of mass destruction sound
deeply concerning for to me at least. Max is the
other sort of technologist on the panel. What
what are your reactions to what Stewart said.
Yeah i'd like to follow up on the supermarket
comment that Stuart made there because I think
the biggest misconception that
we see in a lot of governments
and even in the United Nations I think is that
this is primarily a military issue, when it's
actually primarily a civilian issue. And I was
so happy to hear from you Maya you know how the
ICRC cares about humanitarian issues more broadly
than just military ones. Last year for example
many people think that most people who were
killed by weapons last year were killed in
wars or other armed conflicts. That's not true.
Most people who were killed by weapons last
year were not killed in Syria, Afghanistan,
Iraq, or Yemen. Yhey were killed in Mexico
why? Crime primarily. And it would be incredibly
naive to think that if you had these slaughterbots
things as cheap and small as a smartphone
available in supermarkets or more likely
any arms black market right?... at
the same price as a kalashnikov rifle,
that these would that we wouldn't see exactly the
same use cases there. Just like most people in the
past were killed by weapons in civilian context,
they will even the future too. But now with these
weapons instead that's the primary use case. And
do we really want to live in a future where anyone
who for whatever reason wants to
kill anybody anonymously can do so
for a very affordable price and not even
get caught? That would be the end of open
society as we know it. And it's a much much
bigger issue I think than military issues.
Thank you Max. And I guess I would add to what you
both you and Stuart have said about the ubiquity
of these and sort of this idea of them being
available in supermarkets is the other side of
this is they may not necessarily even be produced
by the same military producers that we think of
right? At least from what we've seen so far on
the trajectory of autonomous weapons is a lot of
the people looking into making these can be sort
of small private companies because exactly as you
say, these are not terribly expensive or sort
of difficult to make. Richard, how do you think
through the problems that these systems raise? Are
they similar or different concerns that you have?
Yeah, I mean I think this this is an issue
where you can bring together and justifiably
there are a wide range of different problem
framings as I would describe them. And i think
in my mind I tend to work out with from the sort
of narrower to the to the wider. I feel like
at a more, at the most fundamental level where
I see a sort of moral set of moral anxieties is
in any of these machine systems you know you're
using sensors and you know computers to analyze
sensor data inevitably you know machines don't
see people. They don't see humans as humans. They,
they're categorizing the world into certain
pre-programmed classification structures,
they're applying labels to things based within
certain rigid structures. And if we're applying
labels to things through machines and then
labeling them to be subject to the application
of force there's a reduction in that process
of the reality of human existence into simply
a pattern of data to be to be processed in a,
in a mechanical way effectively. So, in that
process of functioning I think when it comes to
machines targeting people say there is immediately
a degree of sort of reduction and a loss of
our humanity in that in that sort of process.
I think that's there fundamentally but I think it
just gets worse if you know in Stewart's examples
if you start to imagine how either deliberately
or inadvertently because of the biases inherent in
certain data sets you start to identify as enemies
people of particular skin colors or people of
particular genders and the like. I mean the way
we start to formalize these these processes of
prejudice in the world and and tie them into the
application of force I think there's, there's all
sorts of concerns in that space. So again, drawing
a line against systems that would target people,
I think is a is a fundamental moral moral response
and then there's more practical sort of pragmatic
concerns that you start to lose control I mean
we civil society have framed our concerns on
this issue often in terms of the need to retain
meaningful human control. I think there is a
sort of tendency for a natural rejection of the
idea of machines making decisions about killing
but the the point at which a decision shifts
from being a human making a decision to a machine
making decision isn't entirely straightforward.
There's a there's a sort of, there's a scaling
of understanding and perhaps human contextual
knowledge that goes on in these situations. So so,
that's another area of concern. That we start to
see essentially an erosion of our expectations for
what people know when they use force. If it starts
to become reasonable for people to simply to put
their faith in machines and and actually have no
real understanding of the contextual implications
of that, that also produces major problems both
practically for who gets killed, harm to civilians
is a significant concern, but also then these
potentially unintended scaling of effects which
I think where you start to get security
concerns you know is it possible that
incidents occur inadvertently and they start to
escalate through these interconnected systems
into wider societal concerns. So I think there's
a range of moral and practical, they have legal
implications. I guess the ICRc can speak well
to that. And I think wider than all of this
there's these wider questions which Max
alluded to about our relationship with
technology and society, our relationship
with these automated decision makings and
decision-making systems in other areas of our
lives. If we can't draw lines against this,
what does it mean for how we as people are going
to relate to technology in the, in the broad
sense? And how are we going to actually control
our own future in relation to technology? So
there's a lot of implicit issues implicated in
this subject matter which I think also means it
will demand a response, thanks. Excellent Richard.
Yeah, I think you've hit on some really great ones
there, that you know this idea of sort of digital
dehumanization I know is something you guys have
talked about a lot. And this idea of reducing
our humanity to a sensor input is something that
is deeply frightening and disconcerting. You also
mentioned the legal and Maya, do you want to jump
in here on how the ICRC thinks through some of
these issues and why you guys have sort of engaged
on this topic in particular? Sure, well first of
all I should say that I mean we totally see this,
these sorts of risks and concerns as others have
mentioned security concerns, concerns for peace,
non-proliferation, conflict escalation, and
so on, I also take this opportunity perhaps
to say a little bit how the ICRC views or
understands autonomous weapons which is slightly
different from some of the presentations that,
that we've already heard. So for us, what really
sets autonomous weapons apart from other weapons
is that they select and apply force to targets
without human intervention in the sense that
after their initial activation by a human being
the system self initiates force application. It
is it is triggered in response to information
from its environment received through sensors
and on the basis of a generalized target profile.
And so in our review this manner of functioning
is already a reality today. So this is not only,
this is not a future only concern. And, for
example, mines and sense of used weapons function
in this way certain so-called loitering munitions
or active protection systems and certain missile
and rocket defense systems. And of course this
way your functioning could be applied to a wide
variety of other weapons and munitions. And so
these can be relatively technically rudimentary,
or complex. And in our view they need not rely
on artificial intelligence or machine learning
techniques. But they may and they probably
increasingly will. So with that said, what
autonomous weapons then from this perspective have
in common is that the user does not choose and may
not even know the specific target, the concrete
target that triggers a strike. And therefore,
doesn't know the precise timing or location
of the resulting force application. And this
loss of human control and judgment in the use
of force brings with it fundamental ethical
concerns that Richard has already
mentioned. In effect substituting
human decisions about life and death with sensors
software and machine processes and of course,
it also brings particular challenges for users of
the weapons in terms of being able to anticipate
and limit the effects of autonomous weapons
use. And that of course carries a risk
for those affected by armed conflict. Notably
civilians, but also soldiers or the gomba wounded
soldiers for example. And with it challenges
for compliance with the rules of international
humanitarian law, notably the rules that govern
the conduct of hostilities. So for example
there is a risk that an autonomous weapon that
is intended to strike military personnel carriers
be triggered by a civilian car. And there is
also a risk that civilians and civilian objects
may be harmed due to an autonomous weapon striking
in their vicinity. So, since autonomous weapon
users do not choose the particular target and
time and location, the specific time and location
of force application, a critical question from a
humanitarian perspective and from the perspective
of compliance with the law is: under what
conditions may uses of autonomous weapons be
reasonably certain that an attack is not
directed against civilians and civilian objects?
And that all feasible precautions are taken to
avoid and minimize harm to civilians? Because
civilians must be protected against the effects
of hostility. Civilians must not be targeted in
war. And as so these these legal rules they demand
context-specific value judgments that do not lend
themselves to being encoded in software processes.
And this specificity context dependency of legal
assessment poses a major challenge to the legal
use of autonomous weapons from our perspective.
Really insightful Maya. That was that was
really helpful. I think something that you
just mentioned too is that you know there's a
certain urgency around the thinking of this.
That it's it's not necessarily science fiction
that we're talking about. We're talking about
technology that exists today in a technological
capability that exists today. And we think about
this a lot when you you sort of hear what Stewart
was saying earlier about applying the principles
of tech to autonomous weapon systems because
they are fundamentally a problem of technology.
And when we think about that, we think
about that sort of exponential curve
at which technology proliferates right? You think
about when you look at cell phone use right? And
how many people have a cell phone.. it's
a nice it starts out slow, and then that
log curve goes up pretty quickly and given these
use reports that we've started to see trickle in
what we've been seeing in terms of increasing
rates of companies getting in to develop these
types of systems something that keeps me up at
night is a worry that we are on the cusp of going
up on that linear part of the curve. Which
is why I see this as a very urgent issue.
Max ,how do you think through
the urgency of of this topic?
It's it's quite striking that when
we made the slaughterbots film
just a few years ago a lot of people were like
ah forget it. This is science fiction you know
decades away. And sadly now they're already
here. We all know what we read in the United
Nations report recently about how they were
used to hunt down fleeing people in Libya
last year for example and we have this um absurd
situation where where there's this aren't this
full this unregulated arms market where small
companies from Turkey and other countries are just
cashing in a lot of profits from from producing
and selling these things to whoever they want
completely legally. And I think politicians
are largely asleep at the wheel here
thinking that they have time to drink coffee
and discuss this for years and years and years.
That's not the time scale in which this sort of
technology works. And you know either we put we
stop this arm's release now before
it gets totally out of control or
we can basically forget about that as this
open society that that that we know and love
and as as Stuart often likes to point
out you know the current position of
powerful nation states like the the US and
Great Britain for instance is completely absurd
they they say on one hand yes you know these
are going to be decisive in the battle space
and no we are not going to build full autonomous
weapons ourselves but we insist on the right for
everybody else including some of the random
Turkish companies that you never heard of to
mass produce these and sell them to absolutely
whoever they want makes absolutely no sense. And
that's why we very very quickly need to get to the
point where there is so much stigma
around these disgusting weapons that
nobody makes them
So Stuart since your name was invoked here,
how close are we getting to buying these
things in the supermarket? And to Max's point
as well, what's your thinking? You mentioned
international security earlier. Is this actually
in the best interest of countries like the US
and Great Britain? The countries that we think of
as major military powers. So, as Max said the the
technology is already there you know slaughterbots
the film came out in November of 2017. the Kargu
drone which is the one that was used in Libya
last year was announced three weeks later. So,
while the Russian Ambassador was scoffing that
slaughterbots wouldn't exist for another 25
years so why are we even discussing this? The
Turkish company STM had already been developing
this product presumably for several years by
that point and announced it three weeks later.
And you know this this point about the the
diplomatic positions of the US and the UK
being absurd. When I went to the White
House, the AI community sent a delegation
of senior researchers to the White House and
we talked to senior members of the national
security council - defense department - state
department, and we described this possibility
of you know anti-personnel weapons being
scaled up and used as weapons of mass
destruction. Their response was, well but
we would never develop weapons like that.
And our response was, well in that case, why
don't you agree to ban them? I mean it just seems
absurd to say well you know we the civilized
governments of the world have such high moral
standards that we would never ever develop and
use autonomous weapons on an anti-personnel scale,
but then if that if that's true then you
should agree to ban them. So I think one
possible conclusion is it's not true. That they
are intending to develop them. Another argument
that they made at the same meeting was that you
know perhaps, you know the civilized governments,
the major powers would develop these weapons, but
they would never fall into the wrong hands. They
would never proliferate. We're very very good
at keeping control of all our weapons. You know
so we pointed out that the United States simply
lost 200,000 automatic weapons in Iraq, they have
no idea where they went and we have a pretty good
idea where they went. Not to mention Afghanistan
and Afghanistan and so on. You know there's a
hundred million kalashnikovs in private hands. So
so that argument is obviously complete nonsense.
And then well what was the first use of the
Kargu of the Kargu weapon it was in Libya where
there's a strict UN embargo on all arms sales.
And it was used by one of the the non-state active
factions in the conflict. And it was used to
attack forces who are running away right? So so it
was already, you know violation of international
humanitarian law. Because it's not militarily
necessary to attack troops who are already running
away. And it was used in violation of a UN embargo
and it was used by non-state actors. So, all the
arguments i think that you know, that we know
what we're doing, you know we're the grown-ups,
we're going to keep control over all this
stuff, I just think they're completely specious.
Yeah I think those are great points you make
Stuart about the rapid proliferation risk.
Especially of these smaller embodiment weapons
that are more of the anti-personnel type right?
That aren't really that different than an ak-47
at at the end of the day in terms of likelihood of
sort of cost to manufacture and complexity
I think Richard actually I mean land mines
can go as little as six dollars each yeah so it's
really you know it's actually a smaller explosive
a lot smaller explosive than a landmine the the
quadcopter part if you want to make a little
quadcopter you can buy for a couple of dollars
and then you've got a tiny little cheap camera
and a chip so I think 25 dollars if you
manufacture these in very large numbers
Totally. Richard on the civil
society side you guys have been
calling for a while for urgent action on this...
Can can you take us through how you see urgency
either similarly or differently than Max and
Stuart? Yeah I mean I think I think we do see
more use more emphasis on these technologies
in practice. I mean there's been
examples here in relation to certain what they're
you know called loitering munitions but we see
this perhaps expansion of existing technologies
and potentially greater greater use of that so
in those contexts we don't necessarily have
transparency or detailed understandings of
actually how those systems are functioning in
practice or what rules are being applied in their
use. So at the very least it feels
clear that we need clarification of
how do people understand the law in relation to
these these systems in practice. So yes, there's a
there's a there's a momentum from in the from the
sort of military technology side. I also think
there's a kind of there's a normative urgency to
this I mean particularly on the anti-personnel
side actually in society antibiotic landmines were
used very widely and a lot of people were killed
and injured and impoverished as a result of that.
So we we undertook the what as a society globally
we undertook the widespread use of a particular
set of technologies that use sensors to target
people and frankly it was a humanitarian disaster.
And the large majority of states have decided to
consider anti-personnel mines illegal as a result.
Some states haven't but the great majority have.
Now there hasn't actually been as yet a widespread
adoption of other systems that use sensors and
algorithms to target people. I think that means
we have an opportunity now it you know prohibiting
systems before they come to fruition that has its
own challenges this sort of navigating negotiating
the boundaries for the future you know
presents difficulties but I think it's
a better challenge to be faced with than trying
to claw back technologies once they've already
become once they've already proliferated and once
more importantly they've become acceptable in some
way. Because there's a danger that that states
then have an incentive to claim the acceptability
of certain technologies. So yeah I think there's
an urgency because we have the opportunity to draw
some lines now which if we don't draw them now
will be more difficult to to create and to pull
back towards in the in the future. So I think it's
a it's an opportunity, it's an opportunity for us.
Completely Richard. And to that
point as well the idea that
how easy it is to claw something back right? It's
if it's a fighter jet that goes wrong well that's
a lot easier to claw back than something that's
small and cheap and has proliferated widely.
Maya on from your perspective I think the word
urgent does appear in the ICRC's recommendations
to the rep cons how how do you guys think through
this topic? Sure we've, we've in fact called since
2015 on states to agree international limits
on autonomous weapons. So that the urgency
is certainly here. I'd also like to sort of
reflect a little bit on what others have said.
It's important I think to keep in mind that
developments in this area developments on the
kinds of technologies that are developed the kinds
of weapon technologies that are developed are the
result of of choices they are not pre-determined.
So resistance is not futile and I would agree
with Richard that we do have an opportunity
here. And we are actually in a fairly sort of
a good place in the sense that we have a deep and
wide-ranging debate on on this issue already. So,
I think we should should keep that sort of this
this this this sense of of urgency but also the
sense of opportunity at the forefront of our
minds when we're discussing autonomous weapons.
For us what what is remarkable is that in pres
so as I said we understand autonomous weapons
in a way that includes certain existing weapon
systems. And in present-day military practice
the the use of these these autonomous weapons is
tends to be strictly limited in ways that can help
reduce humanitarian risks. And that can facilitate
compliance with international humanitarian law.
So for example an autonomous air defense system
these tend to be used only to target typical
military objects in this case incoming missiles
or military aircraft. And in in this case but
also other existing autonomous weapons I think
it is significant that the allegations of use of
autonomous weapons to directly target people they
are emphatically refuted by alleged users. I think
this is significant because it speaks to one of
those moral lines that others have evoked as well
is that in present military practice autonomous
weapons are not used to target persons directly
with the exception of anti-personnel landmines
which have been outlawed by treaty to which
a majority of states has signed up to. Now in
existing practice autonomous weapons also tend to
be used only for limited time time frames limited
duration in well-defined geographical zones
and in situations where civilians and civilian
objects such as civilian aircraft for instance are
are not present so could be around a military
base where civilian aircraft are excluded from
entering the the air space and they tend to
be used under constant human supervision and
with the ability for the users to intervene and
to deactivate the system where necessary. Now
all of this, we think speaks to also not only
practical limits but also sort of normative
limits...things that should remain in place even
as technology allows different uses and what we
are concerned about is that certain trends in
military interests and investments that aim at
that, that aim at using autonomous weapons
increasingly also target persons directly. As
well as a wider range of objects such as vehicles.
As I said, vehicles may also be used by civilians
depending on on the target profile, right? Use in
increasingly populated areas even in the midst of
cities over larger spaces longer periods and
at much larger scale. I think Stuart has has
spoken to this. So, there are these ideas of the
deploying entire swarms. And then, of course, with
much reduced human supervision. And increasingly
relying on artificial intelligence and machine
learning techniques. And considering the speed
at which these developments are taking place
we really believe it is urgent that states agree
an effective international response to the, to the
ethical, humanitarian, and legal and security
risks that we see on the horizon. Awesome. And,
I think that's also a great point you make too
in grounding this conversation is that we're not
talking about putting limits on all applications
of AI and all types of weaponry. There's many uses
of AI. You know we think of things like missile
defense systems that don't have the same types of
raise the same set of concerns and considerations
as using AI and anti-personnel systems, right?
Can you maybe, let's maybe switch gears here now
into the - all right so we have this problem,
we know it's urgent. What is it that we can do
about it? And what are policy frameworks that
may be helpful for this? And maybe you know I know
there's especially for Max and Stuart's thinking
having been in this for a while what may be other
unhelpful suggestions that may be out there? So
Maya will you take us through how does the ICRC
think about what should the world do? What is the
policy response that you guys would like to see
happen? Sure. Yeah, so actually earlier this year
in May the ICRC offered a set of more specific
recommendations to all states with a view to
supporting state's current efforts at establishing
international limits on autonomous weapons. And
with view to ensuring civilian protection in
war compliance with international humanitarian
law. And also ethical acceptability. So concretely
the ICRC recommends that states adopt new legally
binding rules. In particular, certain prohibitions
and restrictions. And so, one type of autonomous
weapons that we recommend that states prohibit
are what we call unpredictable autonomous weapons.
These are autonomous weapons that are
designed or used in a manner such that
their effects cannot sufficiently be understood,
predicted, and explained. And this is of course
a concern that for us is particularly acute with
autonomous weapons that continue to learn targets
during use. Yeah, that would be one example that
for us we find extremely risky and would like
to see prohibited. Second, in light of ethical
considerations to safeguard humanity and also to
uphold respect for international humanitarian
law we recommend that autonomous weapons that
are designed or used to target persons directly
should be prohibited. And as we've already many
of us have said this is grounded in a deep ethical
objections to this sort of sort of killing, right?
Life, death decisions basically devolved to
machine processes. And, it also grounded in
concern particularly at acute concerns that
international humanitarian law may be violated
in the targeting of persons via on the basis of
target profiles, right ?Because the user is not
selecting a particular person and therefore is not
in a position to reasonably assess whether that
person at that moment may be targeted. Now, also
with the view to the protection of civilians and
to safeguard humanity, the ICRC also recommends
that the design and use of all non-prohibited
autonomous weapons should be strictly regulated
through a combination of limits and requirements
notably limits on the types of targets such as
constraining them to objects that are typical
military objects. So, typically that are legally
speaking, military objectives by nature. Such as
enemy weapons or enemy tanks. Limits on the
duration, geographical scope, and the scale
of autonomous weapon use and that is aimed in
particular to enable the users to remain aware of
the circumstances of an attack enough to actually
to for human judgment and control to be sufficient
and meaningful in every specific attack. As
well as limits on the situations of use such as
constraining autonomous weapons to situations
where civilians and civilian objects are not
present. And that is, of course, in particular
because of the the risks to civilians if they
are in the vicinity of targets that may trigger
an autonomous weapon strike. And this risk is,
of course, particularly acute where civilians are
present in high density, such as in the midst of
cities. And then finally, requirements for human
machine interaction. Notably, to ensure effective
human supervision and timely intervention
and deactivation when this becomes necessary.
So, these are the sorts of recommendations
that we that we that we put out and
welcome reactions from states and continue to
work towards to support states in this direction.
Excellent. Thank you, Maya. As we close
in these last few minutes of the panel,
Richard from the civil society side of things
how does Maya's policy prescription sound to you?
Yeah, I mean, I think we're also pushing
for a legal instrument. And I think it,
we think it needs to be one
that contains prohibitions.
It's gonna ban systems that can't be used
with meaningful human control. It's gonna ban
systems that would target people. And it needs
to have these other rules positive obligations
to keep control over the use of systems. Because
I think as we've already discussed on this panel,
we have weapons today that work using sensors in
this way. And we need to stop a sort of slippage
of those systems into an unacceptable future.
So, the combination of prohibitions and positive
obligations to retain meaningful human control and
to prevent this sort of digital dehumanization.
A couple of things just to add it's states, it's
governments who have to create international law.
So, in terms of what needs to be done, we need
to push governments to speak in favor of these
responses to push themselves for a legal treaty in
response to this to this issue. And to be honest,
over recent years these issues have been under
discussion in the convention on conventional
weapons. You mentioned it at the beginning,
it's not a forum that frankly is very likely
to lead to an outcome. Even though the majority
of states now internationally who are engaged in
these discussions, the majority of states I think
support a movement to to begin negotiations. So
I think that before too long there will be
frustration with this pattern of talks and I think
there'll be a movement amongst those states who
do want to make progress on this issue to start to
develop a legal instrument more on their own terms
directly working towards this kind of this kind of
outcome. And that leads me really to my to my
final point, which is you know an international
treaty isn't an end in itself. An international
treaty is an instrument that's got to
fulfill certain purposes. It's got to shape the
normative landscape that we're working in. Which
really means the sort of social expectations
what does good behavior look like? what does
bad behavior unacceptable behavior look like?
And we need a legal instrument that sets out
that landscape in a particular direction that
sets our expectations of governments. And also,
flowing down from that, sets our expectations for
the tech sector, for commercial companies, for
arms manufacturers, sets the expectations of where
they need to impose limits on their own practices.
Because ultimately, I think we all socially have
a stake in drawing these lines. We need to create
a social landscape amongst ourselves. We have to
have belief in norms and in laws and in social
standards. We have to have a belief that that we
can constrain you know technology in this respect.
So ultimately it's about feeling empowered.
We need people to feel empowered that we can
draw the lines in this space. And to be honest,
I feel pretty confident. We've done it before on
other weapons issues as a society. We've
found ways to draw lines and they have
saved thousands and thousands of lives, frankly.
So, I think we should have confidence that we can
do the same on this issue. Amazing. Stuart, I know
you need to leave shortly. What are your thoughts
on this topic? I know you've been dealing with
these diplomatic discussions for quite some time.
Yeah, so I think the first
thing I would like is that the
various nations who are discussing this
actually have a clear understanding of what
it is that they're talking about. So, for
example, at the moment there's a proposal
to ban what they call fully autonomous weapons
and what that means is weapons that operate
completely outside the framework of any human
control. And what that means is weapons that wake
up in the morning and decide by themselves that
they're going to start a war with another country,
right? In other words, what they would ban is
the conscious, self-aware skynet that controls
all the terminator robots. In other words,
they would ban something that doesn't exist,
probably will never exist, leaving all other
actual weapons that anyone would actually develop,
legal. So, that's the first problem we've
got to get away from this nonsense that we're
worried about machines becoming conscious
and deciding to go around shooting people.
That is a complete fiction. The other
issue is I'm very concerned about any
treaty that restricts use But not restricting
weapons. I think the the history shows us that the
only practical way to do this is to ban classes of
weapons. We saw this with chemical weapons. Before
the First World War they were banned. But not as
a class of weapons. What was banned was the use
of chemical weapons. You were allowed to develop
them. You were allowed to deploy them. But you
couldn't use them. And, of course, along comes
World War I, everyone has these big stockpiles
and guess what? They got used. And so, you
don't want to create that slippery slope
by allowing the development of these weapons
and then saying oh but we're only going to
use them in these very restricted contexts,
right? Because those very restricted contexts,
you know, as soon as real conflict happens,
you know, those rules are going to go out
the window. You have to have ways of targeting
the manufacturing of weapons on a large scale.
And I don't think we can afford to to let that
go ahead. Because once it goes ahead as Max said
life as we know it will change forever.
Thank you, Stuart. And I know that you have to
leave so I'll also give you a moment here to
say any last words that you'd
like to say on this issue.
I would like to say, Last
words, Stuart. My last words,
you know I share Richard's optimism that
we have been able to do this in the past.
The bans that we have put in place on chemical and
biological weapons have been largely successful.
And, in fact, it was the biologists who pointed
out that creating effective biological weapons
would reduce the security of every nation rather
than increasing the security of the nations who
were producing them. And the same goes for the
development of autonomous weapons. So, I think
the bioweapons example is actually a great one
because when we think about the biological weapons
convention that's been a very powerful treaty in
terms of its efficacy over the years. And one that
hasn't really have the same type of verification
regime that we associate with something like the
chemical weapons treaty. And what that treaty did
it's a great example of safeguarding a science,
right? In that case, biology and by taking the
weaponization of biology off of the table, it
not only mitigated the risks of bioweapons but it
also allowed biology to really flourish as a field
and to grow. And for us to think of biotech as
something that's great and positive and cures
diseases and gives us new medicines. So, one could
imagine here that there could be a similar future
for artificial intelligence where if we sort of
take the weaponizing of AI and AI deciding to
kill people off of the table it helps to open the
doors for the science to really flourish and sort
of reach all of its potential. Max I know this
is something you think about a lot in terms of
the positive potential of AI. Do you agree with
the others in terms of what should be done about
this issue and how do you think through action
on this topic? In terms of the optimism there
on what we can learn from biology, I completely
agree with you. In terms of what should be done
maybe this is my opportunity to maybe annoy the
rest of you on the panel by saying something
controversial. I am increasingly convinced that
we actually need two treaties, not one. Artificial
intelligence is such a general-purpose technology
that having one treaty for weapons that contain
AI is becoming as ridiculous as having a
treaty for all weapons that involve motors
or explosives, you know. And if you instead ask
what sort of division of weapon types makes sense,
it's really very clear that on one hand there are
the big and heavy expensive weapons that are used
against tanks, airplanes, ships, and so on. They
need to be big because you need a lot of power to
blow through a tank or shoot down an airplane,
and on the other hand you have the weapons that
the ICRC wants to ban, which target humans
specifically. The reason they can be so tiny
and small and cheap is because we humans are not
heavily armored, right, and those are precisely
the weapons that because of their low price
and low mass you can become weapons of mass
destruction where where very few can kill very
many. I think we should have completely separate
treaties for the two of them. I think for
the first kind the big expensive ones the CCW
might be a reasonable forum for this because
of course it was as was mentioned already
unpredictable weapons that are
intrinsically destabilizing and maybe
will cause the US and China to accidentally
get into a nuclear war with each other.
That's not in China's interest
or in the US's interest and
that can give the superpowers an incentive to
go to CCW and agree on various norms and rules
for the military aspects here. For the big heavy
expensive weapons. The other stuff doesn't belong
in the CCW at all, right? The CCW is about a
forum for discussing military weapons. It has the
word "conventional" in the name there's nothing
conventional about weapons of mass destruction
where one dude can kill 100,000 people by pressing
a button and unleashing a slaughterbot swarm.
And as we already discussed right?, the main
victims here, the main use cases are civilian,
not military. So, I would like to see in parallel
with the CCW a new forum focused specifically on
weapons that target humans from not a military
perspective but from a humanitarian perspective
saying this is a disaster for civilization as
we know it. It'll cause the mother of all tech
clashes against the AI field and also thereby rob
us of all the great benefits we could get from it
and let these two processes play out in parallel
not wait for years and years and years while the
CCW discusses military things to have all
these civilian things get out of control in
the meantime. Let's see if I annoyed anyone but I
really think this makes sense. Annoyance is good,
but I think while we've heard a lot of different
perspectives here on the "what we should do about
it" there is some fundamentals that go across all
of the thinking which is this idea of needing to
draw a line and needing to prohibit certain types
of weapons and needing to do that in a forum
factor that is a legally binding treaty. And it's
not some sort of political promise or anything
sort of more measly than that. Something that
really is new law around these threats that we
face. I really want to just take this moment as we
come to a close here to thank everyone. It's been
so awesome talking with all of you and we'll just
do one more round of passing the mic here. I know
all of us choose and care deeply about this
issue that we dedicate years of our time to this
and thinking through this so you know any last
thoughts that you have or perspectives that you
want to share. Maya I'll start with you. Thanks,
EmIlia. Yeah perhaps just to come back to this
moment of opportunity that we have here. There's
a real momentum in the discussions on autonomous
weapons systems that are underway. The positions
of states are becoming increasingly nuanced and
sophisticated and with that they also discover
areas of agreement where before they weren't aware
of that. I also think just reflecting a little bit
on what Max just said, this issue like many others
that will be on the horizon I think in the in the
future has the potential for enormous complexity.
But for political action is sometimes necessary
to focus on some fundamentals, elementary things.
So rather than getting too too distracted by the
very the various forms that autonomous weapons
can take, we would recommend taking sort
of a what we like to call a more technology
agnostic approach. An approach that focuses
on the human within this use of force process
and really aims at preserving and maintaining
sufficient human judgment and control. And that
norms around this we can articulate them and we
can formalize them in the form of internationally
legally binding norms without having all the
specificities, all the information about what
autonomous weapons will look like in the future,
what they can and cannot do, and so on. And so for
more generally I would say that discussions in the
CCW and wider discussions on various applications
of developments in science and technology I
think they really benefit from diverse people
contributing to them. And contributing
in particular to debates deliberations
on the acceptability and the desirability of new
weapons and of course technologists, philosophers,
social scientists, and other knowledgeable people
really all have a stake in this because ultimately
this is about our common humanity about the rules
that protect us all in in case in case of war. And
so it's really critical to foster these sorts
of dialogues among different communities of
practice and the wider public and the Future
of Life Institute is doing a great job at
supporting at enabling these sorts of
discussions. So, thank you very much for that.
Thank you Maya. So well said and we so deeply
respect the work that you do and the ICRC does
and I'm so thrilled to have you with us today.
So we we greatly appreciate it as well. Richard
you're kind of closing thoughts? Yeah, thanks
Emilia. And perhaps picking up on some of
the themes there I mean the Stop Killer Robots
Campaign is a partnership of you know hundreds of
organizations people working together coming from
different backgrounds concerned with this issue.
I've worked on the development of a number
of international legal instruments and
political instruments on weapons and all of those
processes have relied ultimately on a partnership
of states along with international organizations
like the ICRC, UN agencies and UN officials
and then civil society and the wider social
community of stakeholders. And I think
that's going to be the key to to making
progress on this issue. Like Maya,
I would pay tribute to the work that FLI has done
particularly bringing the voices of technologists
and scientists into this, you know, so strongly
into this debate because those voices are you know
fundamentally important in this issue of our
relationship to technology in society. I think
we have these partnerships building up now this is
basically back to grounds for optimism. I think we
have a majority of states who are engaged in the
discussion speaking up in favor of the need for
negotiations. They may not be able to bring that
to full fruition through the through the CCW, but
we have as a basic foundation a majority of states
recognizing that this issue needs negotiations.
We have an agreement more and more
around a policy orientation that contains
prohibitions and regulations,
prohibitions and restrictions, and
I think whilst there's areas of divergence
within that a recognition that this is about
keeping human control in the use of force
and avoiding a sort of dehumanization
both of the people that you know would be killed
but also perhaps of ourselves as you know if we're
complicit in that in that process. So I think we
have this greater and greater policy coherence,
building partnership of states, civil society and
international organizations and a wider community
paying attention to the issue. I think that
negotiations of a treaty will begin on this
in the next few years. The exact route to that is
you know something we're working on. But I feel
very confident based on past experience that
that is going to come about. I can't guarantee
it'll be two treaties. Max may be raising the
raising the bar a little bit here, but I think
we can get one treaty that responds directly
to our concerns and that challenges states
to come to the table and to sign up to
it and to set some standards in society
how we keep you know keep our humanity in the face
of these technological changes. Thanks. Thank you,
Richard. And to avoid being a gratitude fest, but
I will go there is thank you for your leadership
on this and also as you've said you know with the
campaign it's something that's reflective in the
composed of hundreds of organizations around
the world that have been working tirelessly to
advance the types of thinking on this issue and
the policy proposals that we have today. So also
taking a moment to recognize how many different
organizations and people are working so hard every
day to get us towards that goal to get us towards
that treaty. Max? Let's see if I can inject some
more optimism here at the end by zooming out a
little bit to the bigger picture. So you know here
we are 13.8 billion years after our big bang,
sitting on this little spinning ball in space
looking out and just into this amazing cosmos
that we've only become aware of the vastness of it
pretty recently. Now why is it that 2021 is a much
nicer year to live in than 5000 years ago when
the life expectancy was 30? Everything we love
about civilization is the product of technology
and that's why I love thinking about
technology and working on technology, right,
but it's important to not take technology as
our new religion and have this mantra oh you
know more technology is automatically going to
be good because technology is not morally good.
It's also not evil. It's just a tool that we
can use to do good or bad things and the key
to get to where we are have gotten so far and
the key to an inspiring future is really to
make sure that it is we humans who control the
technology not the technology that controls us.
And several of you pointed out that there's
no more ridiculous example of the latter than
if you let the technology on its own go out and
decide you know who gets killed and who lives. But
more broadly for the optimism part, you know the
this is a much more fun and inspiring discussion
the business about what to do with AI technology
than it is to talk about nuclear weapons
where you're just the two options are either we
destroy each other in a nuclear war or nothing
happens. There's no upside. Here there's an
enormous upside because our civilization has been
built with human intelligence if we can amplify
this intelligence with artificial intelligence,
suddenly we're not going to be stumped by all
these things we're stumped by now. We will only
be limited by the laws of physics. We can create
an almost unbelievably inspiring future where we
figure out how to cure all the
diseases that are plaguing us today,
we can stabilize our climate, we can enable
life to flourish, people living healthy
meaningful prosperous lives. Not just for the
next election cycle, maybe for billions of years!
Maybe not even only on Earth but throughout
much of this amazing cosmos. You know
it's this amazing upside that really really
makes it so important to ban lethal autonomous
weapons. The point is not to avoid bad
things. The point is to draw that line and
avoid doing these this tiny fraction of stupid
things that would derail us and make us squander
this otherwise amazing opportunity that we have
and the more we can focus on the upside this truly
inspiring future that we want to live in the more
likely it is that we will live in that future.
Thank you Max. And I think something that
you said there that really resonates with
me is the power of AI, right? We're going to go
in one direction or another. It's not going to
be some sort of mediocre future that we have with
artificial intelligence. It's either going to be
one that is that beautiful positive flourishing
vision or it's a it's a pretty dark one, right?
And the ability to steer which direction we go
in lies in our hands today and I think that's why
we're so optimistic is the fact that we
see that vision. We see that vision of AI
transforming the world for the better and we
feel a responsibility to do what we can to
steer towards that and by doing that steer away
from some of these bad outcomes. And as you say
it's important that human control is is front
and center at that process and that as we
develop these powerful technologies we deploy
them and develop them with wisdom, right? And
wisdom on some of these early use cases and I
think that is at the core what we're talking
about with this whole panel today, which is lethal
autonomous weapons are a very early decision we
need to make about our control of AI and steering
it in a which direction it shall go in towards the
future. And we have this opportunity now to to
hopefully get it right so with that I will thank
all of the panelists for being here today, for
sharing your perspectives, and looking forward
to continuing the journey with all of you towards
a treaty, towards getting that decision right
and just i'm so thankful that all of you are
here today. Thank you, thank you all. Wonderful